we're going to do something we hardly
ever do at aj+
use the T word it's our policy not to
use the terms terrorist or terrorism to
label a person group or action we don't
use them for this guy or for this group
or even for this dude why not
because the term is loaded the radical
Muslim terrorists hell-bent on killing
us after all one person's terrorist is
another person's freedom fighter even
though you might disagree a lot of media
outlets aren't consistent in the way
they use the word terrorist a Muslim
gunman immediately labeled a terrorist
but a white guy who flies a plane into a
government building was it terror or
just anger and some people love to
overuse it now mr. Obama is playing
terrorist whack-a-mole to pal around
with terrorists is Hamas a terrorist
organization we don't try to answer that
question instead we describe the person
or groups actions and let you guys make
your own conclusions like when we
covered the Charlie Hebdo attacks we
described them this way gunmen stormed
the office of satirical magazine Charlie
Hebdo reportedly opening fire on an
editorial meeting and saying the Prophet
Mohammed had been avenged and even
though the US government calls Hamas a
terrorist organization we described in
this way Hamas is a Palestinian
political movement with an armed wing
called the isodyne opossum brigades were
da perhaps but accurate the general
meaning of terrorism has changed over
the last century it was referred to
revolutionary movements and then
repressive governments but today there's
actually no universal definition of
terrorism and the UN has been working on
it for over 20 years the US Department
of Defense does have a definition though
they say terrorism is the unlawful use
of violence or threat of violence often
motivated by religious political or
other ideological beliefs to instill
fear and coerce governments for
societies and pursuit of goals they're
usually political that's not broad at
all oh and the State Department and FBI
they have other definitions we've
decided not to use these labels and
we're not alone Reuters has also banned
these terms and the BBC avoids them when
they can as with every rule there is one
exception
you might hear us use the T word when we
attribute it to someone else
like when Lupe Fiasco says this my fight
against terrorism to me the biggest
terror
is Obama you bet we'll cover it words
have a lot of meaning and we want to
make sure that we're getting it right so
how are we doing let us know